[Musique]
la présidente du département nassimah
dindar accompagné de ses élus a reçu les
professionnels du tourisme à la villa du
département ce jeudi 13 avril
l'occasion de présenter la politique de
la collectivité en matière touristique
et sa stratégie de valorisation de son
patrimoine naturel et bâti mentaires
d'avant la réunion nous sommes un gros
propriétaire foncier qu'un acteur
essentiel du développement touristique
pourquoi parce que les corps et les
parcs dont il émane et à la partie est
du département
nous avons là les forêts les espaces
naturels sensibles
j'ai envie de dire 40 % du territoire
le département n'est le propriétaire et
même une grande partie du parti
sommes un acteur patrimoniale
d'importance le département intervient
en tant qu'opérateur financeurs et
propriétaire de nombreux patrimoine
foncier à fort potentiel en particulier
le domaine forestier
l'ambition est d'insuffler une nouvelle
dynamique pour cela l'expertisé les
connaissances des différents acteurs du
tourisme sont essentiels pour nous les
hôteliers aujourd'hui nous serions
évidemment favorables à un développement
raisonner réfléchi en peu de
concertation avec les instances locales
pour le tourisme
nous allons observer celle là de près on
espère pour nous là que tous ces
sentiers sur le village et ou même
ailleurs sur l'île à au niveau
touristique soit vraiment ouvrir des
revalorisations il a correctement
bienvenue en place sur la sphère
professionnelle
enfin en à une précision sur ce que ces
départements haut niveau sur disciples
et surtout on s'aperçoit que le
département a beaucoup beaucoup de sites
finalement en gestion
et des sites majeurs sur lesquels la
réunion pour se développer et faire de
ce projet un pari de l'innovation afin
de faire de la réunion destination
reconnue sur l'échiquier international
mais aussi de favoriser la création
d'activités porteuse d'emplois
[Musique]